if you take the number two and multiply
it by a given Vector it means you
stretch out that Vector so that it's two
times as long as when you started if you
multiply that vector by say 1/3 it means
you squish it down so that it's 1/3 the
original length when you multiply it by
a negative number like 1.8 then the
vector first gets flipped around then
stretched out by that factor of
1.8 this process of stretching or
squishing or sometimes reversing the
direction of a vector is called scaling
and whenever you catch a number like 2
or 1/3 or 1.8 acting like this scaling
some Vector you call it a scalar
numerically stretching out a vector by a
factor of say two corresponds with
multiplying each of its components by
that factor two so in the conception of
vectors as lists of numbers multiplying
a given vector by a scalar means
multiplying each one of those components
by that
scaler